what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Craven's last hunt right
we technically started it and didn't
finish it in the last video that we did
Craven the hunter basically killed
Spider-Man right he considered Peter
Parker to kind of be like the ultimate
test right the ultimate hunt hence the
name Craven's last hunt what he does in
this video is he becomes Spider-Man now
there's a really really cool narrative
that kind of runs through this whole
thing here right which is to say once he
dons Peter Parker's Spider-Man suit it's
not really about him replacing
Spider-Man it kind of is but it kind of
isn't right he says like the spider lies
in a grave a hundred miles from here
down in the darkness blasted into
Oblivion by my hand because he literally
shot him in the face with a shotgun or
at least shot him in the chest with a
shotgun my greatest enemy my greatest
Tormentor that black hideous Beautiful
Beast by my hand but it's not enough to
Simply destroy him I must become him I
must prove myself Superior to him and
laugh in the face of his hovering ghost
so one of of the things to know about
the relationship between Craven and
Spider-Man is that it's not your typical
like Spider-Man versus Dr Octopus type
relationship or something along those
lines in a lot of ways the stories of
Craven the hunter in Marvel Comics very
much mirror the most dangerous game if
you guys ever read that book it's
basically the classic story where a guy
invites people to his island or kidnaps
him and takes him to his Island and then
he hunts them right because he considers
man to be the most dangerous form of
game that he can possibly hunt Craven is
very much like that in relation to
Spider-Man and while I wouldn't
necessarily go so far as to say that he
saw Spider-Man as a kind of God what he
did do is see Spider-Man as this almost
undefeatable being right this person
that if he were to overcome him and then
basically become the spider it would be
like the greatest achievement in his
life because as a hunter it's what he
lives for but what he does is he tells
himself once he enters into this place
he says no I am craving off the man I am
Craven the Hunter and my metamorphosis
this is not yet complete my
metamorphosis I must merge with the
spider with its Blasphemous sacred
Essence now the cool thing about this is
that while I doubt it was the intention
of Marvel and jmd Matthias at the time
this story was written this very much
feeds into the work of J Michael
strzinski when it came to like the other
in the Spider-Man comics which is to say
the whole idea of spider totems and so
on and so forth the nature of Spider-Man
and like the inheritors and so on and so
forth this idea that Peter Parker as
Spider-Man is representative of
basically animal totems right he
represents the spider in the entire
spider landscape different powers and
abilities that effectively come with it
but for Craven his metamorphosis right
his transformation into the spider is
basically confronting his fear of the
spider so one of the things you guys
will probably notice because this story
came out way back in the day it shares a
lot of similarities with Batman in Bane
right like Bane literally left Santa
prisca and then track down Batman and
Gotham City because he was having quote
unquote nightmares about a bat and
defeating Batman would conquer those
nightmares and kind of elevate him to a
greater level as far as he was concerned
in his own mind with cravenous very much
the same way right he says like don't
question drink herbs and roots and
juices poisons fruits and flowers let
them pervade your mind widen it shatter
your craven-ness and let in spiderness
let it in let in pain so it's one of
these things where for him not only is
it about just like taking over the role
of Spider-Man or at least kind of
replacing Spider-Man to a degree
although not necessarily it's becoming
the spider this almost mythical entity
that exists out there elevating himself
to an almost god-like status and all the
powers and all that kind of stuff that
comes with it the crazy thing here is
that once he does this of course he
experiences pain but then in turn he
starts to have what you could argue to
be this massive hallucination now given
the fact that it is Marvel Comics and
Marvel Comics is really nothing more
than just kind of Flights of Fancy in
both written and drawn form you could
say that like this giant spider is
actually happening but at the same time
it really seems more just due to him
hallucinating right to kind of
hallucinogens and so on and so forth but
he's physically fighting it and
physically engaging it because this is
representative of the thing that
terrifies him right this great powerful
beastly spider that exists out there
this Force that's always defeated him at
every single turn if he can conquer this
he can become the greatest hunter who's
ever lived the greatest thing in his own
mind and so that's why Craven's last
Hunt is as much a psychological story as
it is a Spider-Man story it's arguably
the greatest Spider-Man story ever
written depending on how you look at it
but nonetheless it still kind of Falls
in that way now what it does here for a
second is it does transition to Mary
Jane Watson in the sense that like some
guys are basically hassling her and
really harassing her and that kind of
thing she tells them off and really kind
of walks away way and then it jumps back
to Craven that's an important thing
because we're going to circle back
around to that here in a second but even
Craven himself in the midst of all of
this says like this is insane I stand
before a shadow that doesn't exist a
shadow created by my own drug mod
there's nothing to fear I am Craven
cravenov the hunter man there is no
spider no Supernatural creature that
inhabits men's Souls there is only
Spider-Man a costumed adventurer who
through sheer luck has managed to beat
me time and again down through the years
but it's also one of these things where
he's kind of like none of this is real
he literally kind of Muses and says but
now I have finally beaten him and I want
to magnify that defeat only by taking
his place by proving myself Superior to
him by proving myself a better
Spider-Man can my victory have any
completeness any meaning so for those of
you guys who have been reading
Spider-Man for a number of years and
specifically during dance slots run
obviously superior Spider-Man has very
big notes when it comes to this why
because the motivation of Dr Octopus and
basically taking over the body of Peter
Parker in that story and becoming
Spider-Man was rooted in this very thing
I will become the new Spider-Man I will
become a better Spider-Man so that's one
of the reasons why Craven's last Hunt is
such a landmark story in Marvel Comics
when it comes to the Spider-Man Mythos
because in a lot of ways it informed so
many other stories that came after it
decades after this came out other
stories built off the work that it did
and so this is when Craven really starts
to take control of the situation and he
says yet I insist on creating this thing
this spider I cannot face the fact that
a man was capable of besting me will
stand up then and will face him but what
if it's true and so it's one of these
things where it kind of feeds on this
idea what if Spider-Man is just like
some kind of mythological being right
like what if Peter is representative of
some kind of mythological power that
exists out there hence the nature of jmd
Matthias is like the other so on and so
forth right Peter Parker embodying this
mythological spider type being and
turning into quite literally a giant
spider himself what if that's true what
if this is really the case what if
Spider-Man is not just a kid out there
who got his powers by whatever Manner
and whatever means because Craven
doesn't fully know the origin of
Spider-Man nobody really does at least
outside of Peter and the people that
he's chose to divulge that to but what
if it's not just that right what if he
really is this just mythological
character and so that's what's so cool
about this is it gives you insight into
the mind of how Craven sees Spider-Man
he wants to believe that Spider-Man is
just a kid who is a superhero and has
defeated him several times but on the
other hand there's the possibility that
maybe there's something else and a lot
of that is because when it comes to
Craven the hunter the notion of like
odds and mysticism and beings of crazy
powers and all that kind of stuff that's
not like a major part of his character
right he's by no means tied into like
the midnight sons and Doctor Strange and
Ghost Rider or anything like that but
there is this almost kind of
Supernatural Viewpoint of the various
things that he hunts so it is really
interesting to see him see Peter Parker
in that way now ultimately he's kind of
like over just completely engulfed by
like this these Fighters they're just
kind of overtaking him and so on and so
forth but he does end up escaping from
all of them right like overcoming his
fear and that's when you switch back to
Mary Jane Watson because these two guys
that she basically told off they start
following her and as they continue to
follow her eventually Spider-Man shows
up now she's excited to see him because
she doesn't know that Spider-Man has
been shot by Craven the Hunter and he's
buried underground 100 miles away she
just sees that Spider-Man is there but
her immediate indication that it's not
Peter Parker comes in the form of the
fact that when Craven fights these guys
he is is brutal towards them I mean he
beats them within an inch of their life
and almost kills one of them right way
more damage than Spider-Man would ever
do because Peter Parker would like try
to scare them off or maybe he would web
them up and stick them to a wall but he
certainly wouldn't practically beat them
to death right or nearly beat them to
death that just wouldn't happen and that
level of ferocity and that level of
anger and rage right just that kind of
deadly nature coming from this situation
immediately tells MJ this is not Peter
and she's actually going to become kind
of a major player in the future of
Craven's last hunt in terms of tracking
down and figuring out what's going on
with Peter Parker but that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
if you want to get caught up on Craven's
last hunt make sure you click this link
to the playlist so you can watch the
first video and I will catch you all
later peace